KIKI MARCONDES: Hello, everyone.
And welcome to
IPG Online Meetup.
My name is Kiki.
And I'll be your host today.
We're broadcasting live from
Google London headquarters.
And we are all very excited
to have you joining us today.
Back by popular demand, today
marks the eighth IPG Online
Meetup edition.
And our goal is to be as
interactive and educational
as possible.
So in today's
session, we are joined
by Oliver Ogg and Paul Rohan.
And we will talk about
driving banking innovation
in the Age of Assistance.
So first, Ollie talking
about FIS disruption.
We're going to have Paul Rohan
talking about the role of APIs
in banking.
And then we're going to
go to a fireside chat.
As always, we will provide you
with plenty of opportunities
for participating
and asking questions.
So before we start,
few reminders.
Please ask questions
throughout the session.
We will have a dedicated time
to answer to all the questions
so feel free to submit
them at any time.
And also to ask questions,
use the link here
or click on the Ask Question
button on your watch page.
Now I would like to
welcome to the stage
our special guest Paul Rohan.
Paul is an author of two
books on open banking
and has a vast experience
working with C-suite
on the area around the
world and also Oliver Ogg.
So without further
ado, grab a drink,
make yourself comfortable,
and let's get started.
Over to you, Ollie.
OLIVER OGG: Thanks, Kiki.
So over the last
couple of weeks,
I've just been keeping an eye
on those that have registered
for this online meetup.
So welcome.
But I see we've got
a lot from the world
of financial services.
But we do also have
quite a few who
don't directly, at
least today, work
in the world of
financial services.
So I thought it'd be a
good opportunity just
to take a holistic view across
what we see in the world of FIS
disruption and see
some key themes that I
think are relevant to all.
So first of all, the
concept of being open.
So the fintechs, the digital
natives are, by default,
as part of their DNA, open.
They expose their core data,
their core services via APIs
so that it is extremely easy
for others to work with them.
That's quite different
from the incumbents.
So ask today during this meetup
what is right for the business
that you work in and
what's the appetite today.
It could be a significant shift.
Second, leveraging data.
If you work for an
incumbent, you are no doubt
sitting on an extraordinary
wealth of data
that I'm sure is not
being fully leveraged.
Often, there are
significant challenges
around data being in silos.
So at least internally,
expose this valuable data
set within the business so that
other parts of the business
can consume it easily.
But also, think about
these new data products
that you could surface up as
APIs to external participants.
These can be
incredibly valuable.
Think about the
insights that you
can derive from your scale and
the data on which you sit on.
Third, gravitational pull.
So why would others
want to work with you?
Now it could be that
it's incredibly easy
to work with you.
It could be your scale,
perhaps the number of customers
or the number of products and
services that you offer today.
Perhaps it's the unique
insight that you've managed
to derive out of your data.
It could well be a combination
of a number of things.
To think about what
is the unique value
that you can offer
to attract others.
Your traditional
ego is certainly not
going to be enough
going forwards.
Fourth, cross-industry
ecosystem.
So we see this for two main
reasons, the first being
about maintaining relevance.
So for many businesses
today, in order
to maintain a continual
relevance to their customers,
they are looking to
bring additional products
and services from other
industries to the channels
that they own that
they can drive down
to their existing customer
base so that, as a customer,
I'm more continually engaging
with that particular brand.
Secondly, we see
it when an industry
is seeing some level of
disruption and the more severe
the disruption, the more
cross-industry collaboration
we observe.
And this is a defensive
and offensive play
in a competitive landscape.
So take a step back and
consider your organization's
own competitive landscape
and, again, the appetite
of this cross-industry
ecosystem play.
And last but not least,
the ability to execute.
So there are lots of
challenges in doing this well.
There will be organizational
mindset issues.
There will be leadership issues.
There will be
organizational structures,
personal egos in the way.
So this is not a hard--
sorry.
This is not an easy thing
to immediately solve.
And of course, talent is
hard to attract and maintain.
So these are five
very common themes
that we see in the world
of financial services
but certainly in
other industries
and hopefully will be useful to
have in the back of your mind
as we explore this
topic in more depth.
Thanks very much.
Over to you, Paul.
PAUL ROHAN: Thank you.
Thank you, Ollie.
And good morning, everyone.
I'm going to talk about the
role of APIs in banking.
And while a lot of my comments
will be specific to banking,
they can probably apply
to any really traditional
mature business that's been
around a long time that
wasn't born on the internet and
is now seeing both the threats
and opportunities from
digital ecosystems.
So I have to cover four
themes today, four topics.
And I'm going to just
call them out now
to give you a chance to consider
them at a very high level
and maybe perhaps contribute
any questions that you
have to our discussion.
We have a fantastic
vantage point
at Google Apigee in
that not only do we
serve a lot of banks and
financial services companies
globally but we work
across every vertical.
And we think there's
something much bigger
happening than just banking or
open banking, which we would
call the Age of Assistance,
which I'll come on and describe
in a bit more
detail but we think
to be relevant, and
responsive, and fast in the Age
of Assistance.
API products aren't
just an optional extra.
Excuse me.
We think they're
absolutely essential.
Secondly, the world
of digital ecosystems
are radically different in terms
of how people think and behave
in terms of growing
their business
and managing their business
strategy, and technology,
and managing their brands.
And there's lots of
discussion around mindset
and corporate culture.
But to be really
explicit here, we're
saying we think work is required
on both computer systems
and belief systems.
Sounds a bit odd but
come on to discuss
that in a bit more detail.
And we think it's
insufficient just
to do work on your
computer systems
and not work on
your belief systems.
We think this will prevent you
scaling or certainly getting
the full benefits of
digital ecosystems.
Then I think brand
is very important,
brand strategy, for a couple of
reasons-- for several reasons,
in fact.
Firstly, brand strategy
has a much longer duration
than business strategy
or technology strategy.
So your technology strategy
or your business strategy
might have one or two years to
run whereas brand strategy is
very long term 5 to
10 year thinking what
type of emotional
reaction and response
do we want to get from the
marketplace, far broader
than just our specific
products and services.
Often people who are from a
pure technology background
say to me, banks are
in terrible trouble
or the banking industry
is in terrible trouble.
Their user interfaces, the
user experiences aren't good.
They must be out of
business in a few years.
And my response
is, well, we need
to reflect on that because
the banking industry, based
on which historian you believe,
could be up to 4,000 years old.
So it has thrived and survived
many evolutions in technology.
So we have a view
from much observation
that maybe the brand
purpose of financial brands
won't be changed hugely
by digital ecosystems.
However, brand audiences will be
changed in a very radical way.
And then lastly, what will
be a great financial brand
experience in the era
of digital ecosystems
and in the Age of Assistance?
And we think that the financial
brands that treat developers
as customers and
approach them entirely
as they would
approach customers are
the most likely to scale
and succeed in this world.
So firstly, what do we mean
by the Age of Assistance?
And in the context
of that, we think
it's very much a
hyperconnected world.
And we would define
this as that it's
impacting all services, not
just financial services,
and that customers are now
expecting their favorite brands
to work together to provide
connected experiences
in digital ecosystems.
And if that sounds
a bit far away
or theoretical for a traditional
financial services company,
you need to consider
many aspects of this
but focus in on
customer journeys.
So how does your company
define customer journeys?
Is it a long time since you've
reflected on what they mean?
Do you mean customer
journeys by they
knock on the door of
your store or your branch
or they knock on the door of
your proprietary digital app
and then customer journey
management is ushering them
to the right solution, the
right product to consider,
the suitable service
that you have
for that stage of
their life cycle?
The big concern for companies
that are adopting that mindset
is that there's a new
generation of buyers,
whether they are young
consumers or young businesses,
who are on a journey
to a digital ecosystem.
And they expect their favorite
brands and favorite providers
to collaborate and
provide a connected end
to end experience.
So in reality, they're on a
journey through the ecosystem.
And if you wish to
serve them and remain
relevant and one of
their favorite brands,
you need to push your services
out there into that environment
and let them use those services
through whichever interface
is suitable, and
appropriate, and contextual.
So in that context, rethinking
what you mean by a customer
journey and focusing in
on the young generation
and how they see
customer journeys
causes a major rethink of
not just your brand strategy
but also your business strategy,
your business architecture,
your technical strategy
and, if all of these things
are going to work, your mindset.
And this mindset
needs to be shared
right across the organization
across all key roles
from the top to the bottom.
We talk to many banks about
digital transformation.
And often their focus
can be quite narrow.
And they believe that
transformation involves
using new technologies,
and doing new things,
and doing things in new ways.
And often we have to remind
them that transformation
is a combination of two things.
It's both starting the
new ways, doing new things
with new technologies, but
also effectively stopping
the old ways, stopping
using the old technologies,
stop using the old methods.
And it's useful to consider
the Age of Assistance
from this perspective.
So we would argue very strongly
that, in the Age of Assistance,
only API enabled collaboration
is going to help you keep up
and is going to be relevant.
So look at some of
the ways in which
a traditional financial
services company or indeed
any traditional
organization might partner.
And they would have
historically focused
on things like joint ventures
or strategic alliances.
And a joint venture
is incredibly precise
and that a separate
organization is set up to do it.
But it's plagued with problems.
It's very slow to get together.
You can have a clash of cultures
inside the new organization
from people from two
different organizations.
It takes an incredible
amount of preplanning.
And if it doesn't work out,
it's very hard to exit.
Strategic alliances
aren't quite as rigid,
but they're very, very loose.
And they're slow
to get to market.
You're assembling projects
inside both organizations.
And it's tough enough to
assemble a project inside one
organization but to collaborate
across two organizations
using projects is incredibly
difficult. So very hard
to coordinate and ambiguous
about who's doing what.
And the crucial flaw
that both of them
share apart from being
slow, or rigid, or loose
is that it's not reusable.
It's specific to
that collaboration
whereas API enabled
partnering, the investment
is reusable so you try out
an API with one partner.
Turns out to be a good
API but the wrong partner.
Move swiftly onto the next one.
It's fast to market.
There's automated
processes behind the APIs
which everyone can trust.
There's automated
fast onboarding.
Companies that go
partnering use the APIs move
from onboarding of partners
that last months into onboarding
a partner that lasts hours.
And there's no barriers to exit.
The investment is reusable.
You can move on to other
partnerships, and other ideas,
and other collaborations
incredibly quickly.
And within this
world, you can come
across unanticipated
opportunities with your APIs
that no one in your organization
could have imagined before you
published those APIs.
So we have a strong view
about the Age of Assistance.
We think it straddles all
verticals, not just banking.
So we sell API
management software.
You buy our software.
The problem is sorted.
That's not the case.
We think there's a lot more to
be done than changing computer
systems to handle
APIs if you wish
to be successful in this
world as a financial brand.
So on to belief systems.
And we like to think
that we are incredibly
clinical in our
business environment,
that we make every cold blooded,
analytical economic decisions.
And that is the case,
but those decisions
are built upon a base of
assumptions and beliefs
about how the marketplace works,
how to grow in the marketplace,
how to present services
to the marketplace,
how to segment the marketplace.
The crucial thing
about belief systems
is that they are systems that
people believe all elements
of the system, not just one.
It's not a pick and mix
where they can select.
So in that context, we
think the Age of Assistance
and the digital ecosystems
that are serving
in the Age of Assistance does
require quite a radically
different belief system, a
set of beliefs that are not
only relevant and
effective in isolation
but all connect to each other
and that these beliefs drive
a common set of
behaviors and assumptions
right across the
organization, which
means you can scale
cohesively whatever technology
strategy you're pursuing
or whatever business
strategy you're pursuing.
So for fun, this hearkens
back to those old TV
ads for soap powder.
Do you prefer
brand A or brand B?
But let's consider financial
brand A and financial brand
B that are looking at
the world of ecosystems.
Let's hypothesize that
brand has bought themselves
a brand spanking new computer
system, an API management
platform for ecosystems.
But there hasn't been a
general discussion and revision
of the belief system.
Why are we doing this?
How's the market
going to operate?
How should we present ourselves?
And then brand B,
which is not only
working on its computer systems
but is having a long, and deep,
and broad discussion from
the top to the bottom
of the organization about
what they should believe
about ecosystems and how this
is going to guide our decision
making.
So a simplified but we
think effective summary
of two belief systems--
you can tell we have the
one we like in green and one
we're not so sure about in red.
But the way to read the
slide is down in sequence.
So belief systems are systems.
And all of the individual
beliefs connect to each other.
So there's many traditional
services organizations
which, for the last
20 or 30 years,
if they were asked what do
they believe about innovation
and business development,
they would say, well,
it's the job of our staff.
And because it's
difficult, and slow,
and we're doing
everything ourselves,
we tend to focus on large market
segments to make it economic.
And if we're a bank, we try
to have banking products that
are better than our peers.
And we have to control the
distribution pretty much up
to the line, the point of sale.
And because we're
doing everything
ourselves and we're
using projects
to collaborate with
partners, we can handle
a small number of partners.
And two, because we believe our
logo is our brand and drives
recognition of our brand,
we want our customers
to always use our
digital interface.
And we broadcast loads
of marketing messages
to try and get them to
come to that interface.
And this is not a
common belief system
amongst many of the more
modern services companies
that have grown up,
whether they're fintechs
or other types of new
services companies.
They have an entirely
different set
of beliefs that
all hang together,
that they want their
ecosystem partners to drive
the innovation, and that
they want to be in ecosystems
of collaborating enterprises
that can reach very
small market segments that they
couldn't reach on their own,
and that their brand
experience is driven by how
the brand behaves
inside an ecosystem,
and the crucial skill
for distribution
is orchestrating the
behavior of partners,
and that APIs are fantastic
because they allow you,
when you use the most products,
to manage very large partner
population to drive your growth.
And if we think back to
the 1960s and the use
of the development
of the marketing mix,
which had four P's initially--
product, place,
price, and promotion--
these companies believe
that the P for place
is the digital
interface that happens
to be convenient for the
customer at that point in time
doing what they're doing
in their daily lives.
So in a banking context,
the pay for place
has changed from the
digital interface
that the bank prefers
to the digital interface
that the customer
happens to prefer.
This is a profound
change which gives rise
to significant changes
in computer systems
and overall belief systems.
And these organizations that
operate with the belief systems
that are orientated
towards ecosystems,
they're not obsessed with
their brand as a logo.
They're obsessed with getting
the meaning of what they do
and, crucially, why they do it
to communicate it to their end
users so that they can
form an emotional bond
with those clients so
that those clients will
go looking for those
services as they
go about their daily lives.
So radically different
belief systems.
And we believe
that the banks that
work on just their
computer systems
and don't consider their
belief systems for ecosystems
will struggle to
scale because they'll
have a highly incoherent
internal environment about how
exactly they're trying to grow,
and innovate, and partner.
So this is a simple
graphic we use in Apigee
around the digital value chain.
And this is the old digital
value chain and brand audience
as we see it, which is
financial brands pushing out
their services
exclusively by and large
through their own
brand up and trying
to both provide
services and form
an emotional brand with a brand
audience made up of customers.
We think this is the
expanded digital value
chain for ecosystems, and it
expands the brand audience
where you're trying to get the
same message about what you
have, but also why you
do it, that message
out to both developers and
customers in this environment.
And that's a crucial thing
because the brand specialist
will tell you that what you do
is important for your services,
but what creates long-term
emotional connections
to your clients is that they
understand why you do it.
So you need to get that
message out why you do it
and why it's valuable for
society and the economy
and for the customer
out there and have
developers buy in to that too.
So if you're a
financial brand, these
are the type of brand
messages that are broadcast
and that company
tries to live up
to every day, which is they
are on a long-term journey
with our clients.
They want their clients to
prosper and sleep easily
at night.
They want to protect
them from harm.
They want to be the
financial experts.
They want to be available
where their clients need them.
They want to introduce
relevant other services.
These are parts of the
brand purpose of a bank that
can go back hundreds
of years, and they
will go forward hundreds
of years into the future
no matter what
technologies evolve.
But in digital ecosystems, the
same experience of the brand
needs to be experienced by
third-party developers, who
should by using the developer
program at the financial brand
feel that the financial brand
is on a long-term journey
with them, helping them prosper,
helping them sleep at night,
being the financial
experts, being analytical
about the use of APIs, being
structured, protecting them
from harm in terms of
how the APIs are managed,
being available when they're
needed, and connected
to other wider services.
So same financial purpose in
broad terms of financial brand,
their job is to look after
financial concerns of people
in the economy and in society,
but digital ecosystems
radically expands
the brand audience.
So financial brands
compete with each other.
And they need to compete to
become the favorite brands
within the ecosystems,
both for their customers
and for third-parties.
And we would argue
that the best approach
inside your traditional
financial brand
is to have the same belief
system for customers
and developers.
Developers are our customers.
So it's useful to explore that
topic in a bit more detail.
So in that context,
it's absolutely
natural for bankers today to
go to work in the morning.
And without setting out their
assumptions or their belief
systems, every task they do
that day is based on this belief
that they want as many
customers at the entry
level of their service offering
as possible, as many as
possible at entry level.
And they want feedback
from the customers--
good, bad, and ugly feedback.
They want it so
they can improve.
They want to pay attention
particular attention
to the most valuable or
strategic customers, the most
active ones, the most profitable
ones, the most promising ones.
This is a natural
assumption that underpins
decision making every day.
They want to assign
suitable staff
to deal with particular
types of customers
with the right qualifications
and skills and attitudes
and temperaments.
And you want your
customers to be prosperous.
A financial brand wants
prosperous customers
because that's the key
to prosperity and profit
for the financial brand.
You want to onboard
customers quickly and easily.
And you differentiate
the services
that you offer customers.
And every day,
without specifying
that this is the
underpinning belief,
banker set about solving
problems for their customers.
We would argue very strongly in
the world of digital ecosystems
that the exact same philosophy
around your brand experience
should be applied to
third-party developers.
You want as many as
possible at the entry level.
And we find many bankers
and traditional companies
getting hung up on this.
And we try to say,
listen, you understand
it's just like
funneling customers,
you want as many
possible customers
at the top of the funnel,
and then you filter them.
You want as many
possible developers
at the top of the funnel,
and then you filter them.
And that should be the goal
of your developer marketing
program.
You want their input.
It's going to be tough for
some traditional companies
when they first begin
their developer program.
And even if they manage
the APIs very well,
they are providing a gateway
into potentially old systems
or new abstractions of
data from old systems.
You will get some very,
very tough feedback.
But that feedback loop is going
to be absolutely essential.
So we see many banks
that are incredibly slow
getting mobilized, and they're
very anxious about the end
state of where is this all
going to end up in terms
of new market structures.
And our encouragement
is, listen,
you have to get started.
You have to create
that feedback loop.
You can't stay here
theorizing about how
this is going to work
for another three years.
You need to get started.
You'll get feedback--
good, bad, and ugly.
The bank that gets started
and starts to mobilize
and gets the most feedback
will refine their offering,
will get stronger, and will
form a queue of developers,
and will start to
generate network effects.
You want to filter
your developers,
get the most influential
and profitable ones.
And in terms of that filtration,
monetization is a tactic.
We see many banks
getting hung up
on the idea of API monetization.
I want to be paid
for all my APIs.
I want to know who's
going to use them,
how much they're going to
use them, with what volume.
This is not effective.
Consider how banks
consider bank fees.
For certain segments of the
market like startups businesses
or students, university
students they
don't charge fees because--
or they charge lower fees
because these are
strategically valuable market
segments in the long term.
Other banking
customers get discounts
for using a lot of
banking services
because they're
using them at volume,
so they get a volume discounts.
And other fees are
decided and charged
based on the nature of
usage, the volume of usage,
the future potential of usage.
And in many cases highly
valuable banking clients
that do a lot of borrowing
or do a lot of depositing
don't pay any fees.
The exact same principles
apply to API monetization.
It's a tactic.
If there is a developer
that's driving
a huge amount of
business traffic
that allows lots of
deposits to be taken in
or lots of new
lending to be done,
then you can be quite
relaxed about how much you
charge for the use of the APIs.
You're getting lots
of valuable referrals.
You don't need to charge
that developer for API usage.
So it's just a tactic.
And you learn as you go, and
you refine your pricing tactics
around APIs.
Crucially you want
developers to be prosperous,
just like you want your
customers to be prosperous.
And this is
something to focus in
on because we see some banks
getting very hesitant in case
third-party developers
combine their banking
APIs into third-party services
and have a big success.
And bankers feel
that in some way,
we've lost out on
the big opportunity
even though we would never
have had that idea ourselves
or we would never have
collaborated with that partner
ourselves.
And they need to get
over this because there's
no better developer
marketing than having
one of your developers have
a big success with your APIs.
You want a big queue of
developers to follow.
You want as many developers as
possible at the entry level.
You need to on board and
quickly and easily, just
like customers.
And just like banks tried
to differentiate our banking
services, you need to
differentiate your APIs,
make them faster, make
them more data rich,
make the documentation better,
make the people to manage
your API program more
progressive, more
knowledgeable, make them more
better relationship managers.
And in this evolution,
because banking
is thousands of
years old, bankers
will come to the office,
and the only difference
will be is that they want
to solve problems of both
their customers and third-party
developers with the same energy
and the same purpose, because
they'll be part of their brand
audience, and they will
serve their brand purpose
and will drive new
growth and new innovation
and partnering for banks
and financial services
companies in digital ecosystems.
So they're strong
conclusions that Apigee
has derived from its
fantastic vantage point
in the marketplace
across all verticals.
And there they are
again delighted to deal
in our fireside chat, if people
have questions or ideas related
to this.
OK.
All right, so now let's
pause and get some questions
from the audience.
And once more, to ask questions,
please use the link here
or click on the Ask Question
button on your Watch page.
KIKI MARCONDES: So the
first question here.
Some people say ecosystems will
turn banks into dumb pipes.
What do you think
about that, Paul?
PAUL ROHAN: At Apigee, we
get this question a lot.
And sometimes we have
turn on pickets of,
what you mean by dumb pipes.
But in many ways, we see
it as a cultural reaction
to new customer journeys which
other companies are generating
and a feeling that if
you're not in full control
of the entire journey yourself
with your logo on the front,
that something
major has been lost.
And all we can do is step
back from that and ask--
well, forget about pipes, what
might be dumb going forward,
OK?
And coming back to
the age of assistance
where young people
are increasingly
used to these connected journeys
with their favorite brands
collaborating and providing
a seamless experience
where they might end up
buying several things
from several companies, but it's
been one connected experience,
you have to ask yourself is
it dumb to broadcast messages
to those young people,
those young businesses that
are becoming increasingly
enmeshed in this world,
saying come and look
at our proprietary app,
come and look, break the chain,
break your concentration,
break the convenience, and come
and read up on what we have,
and you'll probably find
it marginally better
as a core product than
something you've just bought.
Too late, OK?
So in the context of that,
we would say step back
because it's a very
emotional statement,
and ask what in this-- is an
environmental change coming?
But financial services are
still very valuable and rare.
It's very hard to get a license,
particularly to take deposits.
Highly regulated, you
need a lot of capital.
This is not a business
that many organizations
will get into easily.
So in that context,
we asked banks
to separate the core purpose
of what they do as bankers
and how all services
are changing.
And once they step
back from that,
we find the question of
dumb pipe, dumb pipe,
we'll be a dumb pipe
is far less sinister.
And then they start to
see the upside, which
is, if I'm not fully in control
of the customer journey,
yes, perhaps my logo
is not on every screen.
But if I use API products, I can
be in 10 times as many customer
journeys.
And I can have a realistic
aspiration to double my sales,
while I'm in 10 times as
many customer journeys.
And if you have
doubled your sales,
that's going to pay for
a lot of marketing budget
to help get across
your brand message, OK.
So we ask people
to step through it.
But it is a question, and it
does reflect this belief system
that we think is
very established,
but increasingly might be the
wrong belief system to have
about how bankers should
distribute their services.
KIKI MARCONDES: That was great.
Thank you so much.
Thanks so much from that.
Thanks for the questions.
We're going to start
the fireside chat now.
And I just would
like to remind you
that we will keep
answering questions
during the fireside chat, so
please keep them coming, over
to you, Ollie.
OLIVER OGG: Great.
Thanks, Kiki.
Paul, a fantastic session.
You've got this unique
global perspective, often
traveling around the world.
When you look across the
entire landscape, I mean,
who's kind of leading the way?
PAUL ROHAN: We see a lot
of leaders and laggards.
But it's difficult to
define an absolute leader
based on geography,
OK, because there's
different environmental factors.
So there's developing
economies, for example,
where there's never
been home broadband,
there's never been
a home laptops.
And there's a whole
new generation
of people getting
connected to the internet
for the first time.
It's all mobile.
It's all cellular.
And to give context, 10 years
ago one third of the world's
global middle classes who
are heavy users of banking
services from financial
brands was in Asia.
In 10 more years, so
in a 20 year shift,
2/3 of the global middle
classes would be in Asia.
And those new consumers
of banking services
will never have
had home broadband,
will never had home laptop.
It'll all be mobile.
It'll all be cellular.
And in that context, and
there is banks in Asia
who are only building APIs
and not building apps,
because they don't think
apps are going to scale.
There's going to be
hundreds of millions
of people who are new customers
with different languages
that will be part of
the platform economy.
They might be managing
their daily lives
to a Chinese platform or to an
American platform or another--
an Indian platform.
They need to expose
banking APIs.
So they're very
advanced with APIs,
but they're driven
by their environment.
Regions where we
see leaders that
are more progressive
as institutions,
we think it comes down
to executive leadership,
OK, because things like
talking about a new belief
system and a new brand
strategy for ecosystem,
that's a C-suite job.
And when you're trying to
use new techniques like APIs
and new market segments
with new partners,
people get a lot more
nervous about things
going wrong than their
tried and tested methods
that they've used every
day for years and everyone
knows what to expect and most
risk management techniques have
been worked out, so
a lot less nervous.
And when there's a setback
in a very mature environment,
people get over it
faster and move on.
Whereas, a setback in
this brand new world
where people are uncertain feel
like the sky is falling in, OK.
So as people are
making the transition,
we think into this new mindset
and a new belief system,
not only do the C-suite need
to fire the starting gun,
but they need to stay engaged,
OK, because they're learning,
people are learning.
And you need to the
C-suite to constantly keep
that strategic goal in mind.
It's a setback.
It's a mistake.
Let's fix it, move
on, move on, move on.
We're entering into a new,
unfamiliar, strange market.
It's like landing in
a foreign country.
We don't know the people.
We don't know the best segments.
We don't know the
best products to sell.
We got to get around the place
and figure out how it works.
And then we'll set very
tough targets for ourselves
and then we'll scale.
So we deal with a
lot of organizations.
And the ones that are least
tentative and most progressive
and get over the learning
experience faster
are the ones where
the C-suite called out
the culture changes as well
as the technology changes.
And then don't just treat it
as another project, come back
to us in six months
when you're finished,
because the odds
of being success
in a very established
environment
is radically reduced, if
they don't stay engaged.
So leadership comes
from leadership.
OLIVER OGG: And
how much permission
does a bank have to get from
that, say, their regulator, is
that an excuse to execute?
Because there must
be some regions where
I guess the local regulator has
yet to say, you must do this.
PAUL ROHAN: Yeah.
The regulatory
environments do differ,
but bankers can get frustrated,
very frustrated sometimes
with what the
regulators specify.
And some of that's justified
and some of it's not.
But you have to
ask ourselves, why
are regulators doing this
or even considering this?
Because they issued licenses
to people to run banks
that will finance the
growth of the economy.
So regulators are looking at
how the economy is evolving.
And it's the age of assistance.
Companies are connecting
to each other.
Consumer experiences are highly
digital and highly connected.
And regulators are
setting a policy framework
around consent and privacy and
all of those conduct rules.
But they are there
underpin good practice
in a world that's
getting connected.
So we encourage our
clients to step--
yes, Article 58 might be
ambiguous and frustrating,
and if only the regulators
around the world
would get together and
synchronize everything.
Put that aside and
ask yourselves,
why are they doing this?
Why are they doing this?
And not only is it the age
of assistance and banks,
if they want to stay
connected to their customers,
need to connect.
But regulators with whatever
degree of effectiveness
are setting themselves
up to regulate conduct
in the age of assistance.
So step up to the why.
And we think that some
banks that get obsessed
about the regulatory
micro decisions
are at risk of missing
the big picture.
Because then they send a
team over in the corner
to deal with the regulations.
And what they should be doing is
getting the whole organization
to consider, how do we develop
and persist with our brand
in this new way of services
being designed and delivered
and consumed?
OLIVER OGG: Great.
Great.
So I guess, I see a common
kind of dichotomy of execution
between those that just see it
in banking as a regulatory tax
to those that are desperately
trying to engage with fintechs,
perhaps desperately trying
to speed up viable ventures
within larger groups.
There's a lot of-- so If
we shift the conversation
from regulatory to the
innovation spectrum,
there's a lot of
innovation theater going on
in the industry.
What are some of the kind of
common pitfalls that you see?
PAUL ROHAN: I think most of
our cultural in that we've--
I think it's a step
forward and a step
back to create an innovation
department in the corner
where everyone
takes their ties off
and you have bean
bags instead of desks.
It's a step forward
in that we need
to loosen up and think about
doing things in new ways
and with new partners
and in new segments.
But at the same time too
with the wrong leadership
or insufficient leadership,
it becomes, well,
that's their job, and
incremental minor changes
is business as usual.
So in the context
of that, there's
a socialization challenge
right across the organization.
And I feel for some
traditional banks,
sometimes for fun, we say we
think they're making progress
because we see the
suits, OK, with the ties
on, but actually talking
in detail about the culture
of the ecosystem
and how do I grow
and, yes, I need to
do the governance,
and yes, I need to do
the risk management.
But how much is enough?
How much is too much?
And so therefore, you
have to ask yourself,
what does the ecosystem
want from banks?
They want stuff that
nonbanks can't do.
They want stuff that you
can't do without a license.
All of that stuff
that is regulated
because badly managed
banks blow up economies,
so therefore they get regulated.
So once you start to say,
well, what do we have
that's valuable
and rare as a bank
that's hard for a nonbanks
to imitate or substitute,
that's the card.
It's payments at high scale.
It's loans at high scale.
It's deposits at high scale.
It's investments at high scale.
And that's the old systems.
You need to get the
data obstructer out
of those systems,
turn it into APIs,
start to learn the feedback
from the developers.
So there is no shortcut.
And the risk is that
innovation theater, which
can be superficial, delays
the real innovation, which
is what do we do that
no one else can do,
because the ecosystem wants it?
OLIVER OGG: And this kind of
ties into my next question
and something you just
referred to earlier
around failure and learning.
When you're working
with C-suite,
do you talk about that in
perhaps a bit more detail,
because I think I see
others sort of pronounce it
as if this is OK to do.
But actually I think
when it came to it,
failure would not be accepted
and heads would be removed.
PAUL ROHAN: I
think you have to--
I think you have to connect
failure to projects culture,
OK.
So why does a
traditional organization
fear failure so much?
Because projects are terrible.
Compared to business
as usual, they're
incredibly difficult to execute.
They are temporary and
unique management structures,
full of people who are
reporting to different people
on temporary assignment.
Most of them don't
reach their goals.
And inevitably, the vast
amount of work they do
is not reusable.
So when you're trying
to innovate and partner
particularly through projects,
failure is a horrible prospect.
A, It's likely.
And B, it's really expensive.
So I don't think you can just
say failure and isolation.
I think fear of failure comes
from feeling that there's
no alternative to projects
and they're an expensive way
to fail for all of those
reasons we just said.
So in that context
when you're trying
to say there's some API
products, if you systematically
start to build them and use
them and market them and get
feedback on them, your failures
are far more economic, so
far faster.
The stuff you did to reach
the failure far faster
is reusable or a lot
of it's reusable.
And you're actively
marketing the outcome
from your innovation to not
just the first person to use it,
but to the next hundred
who could use it.
So I think when
people say, listen,
everyone is afraid of
failure here, it's no.
It's the people are
afraid of failure
because they think there's no
scalable valuable alternatives
to projects culture.
There is.
API products culture, OK.
And I think once
that feeling starts
to-- once an understanding
starts to come and then
crucially support
it from the top,
then the idea of
partnering is API enabled.
It's reusable investment.
I can exit quickly if
the partner turns out
to disappoint, they
don't produce the volume.
It's reusable.
There's automation behind it.
I have a marketing program.
It's as much-- it's an entire
new belief system around how
you're going to collaborate then
projects and oh, it's awful,
I hate it.
How do I get off this thing?
OLIVER OGG: Yeah, great.
I had a moment of realization
actually this year
when I was in a form of maybe
an 18 C-suite of Mia insurers,
mainly CIOs.
And the topic was ecosystems.
But I very rapidly realized
actually that quite a few
had come to that
session with a mindset
that an ecosystem included
strategic alliances.
So I had to really
bring that room along
into sort of saying,
well, actually
that this is our perspective.
Is that something that you
see in the world of banking
as well.
Because I guess banks have been
at the core of an ecosystem.
I think of the
Medici's here, you
know, very vibrant ecosystems
for hundreds of years.
PAUL ROHAN: Yeah.
Sorry, I'm not saying that
strategic alliances will never
be used.
But if you want to have 1,000
partners in an ecosystem
driving your growth,
you want to do it
through strategic alliances.
It has to be API
enabled partnering.
And I do think it's a key
part of the cultural shift.
So you have to say
to people sometimes,
listen, you're talking
to fintechs at the moment
are you looking at
potential partners,
and you imagine who it might
be and you organize a lunch.
You talk about how
you might collaborate.
And then you
assemble projects in
your respective organization.
Even this description
of it is slow.
But consider what you define
by a partnering opportunity.
Should it be when somebody
who you've never met
has started consuming
your APIs and not
just consuming it,
doing it in ways
that you would never
have thought about,
is bringing your services
into new segments
that you never
reached on your own?
They're paying
for the privilege.
Now it's the time
to have a lunch
and say, should this be
a strategic Alliance.
So coming back to the idea
of treating developers
as customers, you want
as many possible partners
at the entry level, and then
begin the filtration process
through API monetization.
So if you think about
fintechs and banks
were talking to a
lot of fintechs,
and there's been a lot of
lunches and lots of beers
and lots of coffees, the
question should be, now
can you use APIs to
filter those fintechs that
want to talk to your bank
into those that can just talk
and those who can talk and
actually simultaneously drive
traffic into your
organization through your APIs
and pay for it?
OLIVER OGG: Great.
And I see there's
a question that's
come through that's
somewhat related
to the theme of ecosystem.
So let's ask this one.
Does Google-- or I'll
just rephrase it slightly.
Has Google created a marketplace
for financial services or will
you do?
PAUL ROHAN: It's a very
beguiling title, marketplace
for financial services.
And financial services is
an incredibly broad church
in terms of what it offers
from the most sophisticated
investment clients down
to the simplest startup
or junior savings account.
And Google is a
global organization.
So in the context of, has
Google created a marketplace
for financial services,
it's hard to describe
what that might be, OK.
There's no doubt that if
you step back and consider
ecosystems as a place where
there are connected experiences
across their favorite brands,
Google is a very popular brand.
People connect
through Google Pay.
Banks connect to Google Maps.
They connect to all sorts
of Google digital assets.
That type of, you
know, are you going
to create something
monolithic where you can see?
It's a connected economy
in the age of assistance.
Google has vast numbers
of APIs, vast numbers
of collaborating partners.
Step back from
thinking that there's
going to be huge moves by
horizontal organizations
or vertical organizations.
People should
consider what will be
the design of the overall
marketplace for all systems
and for all services.
So you're going to find
insurance companies are going
to be dabbling in segments that
they would never have touched
when they had their
old business model,
but now will make some money out
of stuff that's very partially
related to insurance.
Banks will start
to make money out
of nonbanking activities
and ecosystems.
So we think that
developing strategy based
on the positioning
of other companies
is increasingly impossible.
So 10 years ago you could do a
strategy session and everyone
does the SWOT
analysis on the wall--
strengths, weaknesses,
opportunities, and threats.
And when fintechs
came along, bankers
would write collaboration
with 100 fintech names
down as an opportunity.
And then they'd post the
same 100 fintech names down
as a threat.
And all that said was, you can't
devise a strategy that everyone
in the company
understands and is
pursuing based on what are those
47 potential rivals doing now.
If there's a big shift in
the design of the markets
and how it operates, you have
to shift your positioning
towards that design.
So analysts have described
strategy of it's a plan
and it's a position and
it's a pattern of activity
and all different
ways to look at it.
And we think the
pattern of activity
is changing radically, follow
the pattern of activity
in terms of how you behave.
Trying to figure out what 100
other companies are going to do
might be an interesting
discussion to have over coffee.
However, it doesn't
produce anything sensible
for your organization to figure
out in terms of its priorities
for the age of assistance.
OLIVER OGG: Great.
So let's say tomorrow you go
home, and on your doorstep
is a letter from a bank
with a very attractive offer
and you want to become the CIO.
You've had enough
of the Google kale,
the random inflatable
dinosaurs, whatever.
PAUL ROHAN: No more
green trousers.
OLIVER OGG: No
more green chinos.
Now you're looking at this
future untapped technology
landscape of AI,
ML, API, blockchain.
What's the right
level of focus the CIO
should have on this
feature landscape for APIs?
PAUL ROHAN: I
think it was Thomas
Edison said that genius
is 1% inspiration 99%
is perspiration.
So for a traditional
bank, the CIO
getting the valuable services
out of the core legacy systems
and into an API
layer, there's got
to be a lot of perspiration,
OK, and there's no shortcuts.
But as that's happening,
the 1% of the time
that's the most valuable is
evangelizing for the change
in market dynamics.
And in some of those
topics we've just
discovered looking for
inspiration in what's
happening in other
service industries
in terms of how they're
using APIs and ecosystems
and focusing on developers
as a new brand audience
to make sure that they come
to have the same respect
and affinity to your
bank as your customers,
but arguably say very
strongly to banker colleagues,
really the purpose of
a bank hasn't changed.
How services are designed
and developed and delivered
are changing across
all service industries,
but financial
services remains quite
a small, regulated,
highly-capitalized, tough
business.
It's not every business
is going to get into it.
We just need to
rethink the service
part of financial services.
The financial bit might
not change that much.
We have lots of perspiration to
get the financial services out
of the old systems into APIs.
But then more broadly, see
it as a huge opportunity, OK.
There's going to be 10
times as many customer
journeys we can be in if we've
API products that can connect.
So I don't think being
CIO of a traditional bank
with old systems is an easy job.
It can be made easier if all
of these belief system issues
are surfaced and discussed at
the top of the organization.
And then once-- in
any organization,
once everyone starts
adopting the same mindset
and going in the same
direction, any organization
can produce phenomenal outcomes.
OLIVER OGG: Great.
We're coming close to the end of
the time for the fireside chat.
We'll obviously have audience
questions in a moment.
You mentioned the constrained
issuing of licenses.
But I guess that probably
banks have been--
maybe complacent
is the wrong word.
But there's been the
safety net of that.
But obviously that has
changed to a where, right?
There's been more
that's been issued.
And it kind of ties into a
question really around a trust
as well.
So there's a safety net of this
very valuable concept of trust.
How much can banks rely
on the existing license
world, the regulatory license
world, and their perception
of trust in the marketplace to
protect them from disruption?
PAUL ROHAN: I think
they worry too much,
because many of the new
licenses that have been issued
are to initiate
financial transactions.
They're not necessarily to
settle financial transactions
at scale.
Certainly, a license to take
deposits from the public
is still something that
regulators don't hand out
too easily, because a public
panic and runs on banks
is something that can cause a 10
year recession in your economy
with a loss of confidence.
And so, yes, there's a lot
more licenses and with PSD2
and open banking
initiatives to allow
non-banks or more likely
regulated financial
institutions to
initiate payments.
But much of profitability
of the industry
is driven by the ability to
take large amounts of deposits
from the public,
pay 2% on average,
lend back to the
public possibly to tend
to be to younger businesses
and younger people at 6% or 7%
because you need to cover the
small number who don't pay back
their loans and other risks
in relation to that process.
So in the context
of that, I don't
see licenses to build a
balance sheet being thrown out
too easily, because
these balance sheets--
the health of these
balance sheets
are connected to the
health of the economy.
So I do think that banks need
to get their heads around what
is initiation of payments and
the abstraction of account data
and what actually is the
providing of core banking
services, and then recognize
that in this evolution is
opportunities for partnering
at scale that they never
had before.
But these opportunities
will mean nothing
if they don't have API products
to make those partnerships
fast, flexible, reusable.
And in time, the market will
get to a new steady state
with this new dominant
design of how things happen.
And my personal view is that
banking will thrive and will
expand because of the expanded
opportunities and ecosystems.
The question is, which banks
will make the transition
effectively and
which banks won't?
OLIVER OGG: Fantastic.
A great summary there, as well.
If I just go into the
perhaps some kind of
takeaways that
I've really learned
from that fantastic
conversation.
I think, I found that
really how we position
this to be really valuable.
And hopefully the audience, no
matter what industry, just kind
of this a reset of the
opportunity for the industry
and no doubt for your business.
The positioning around the
criticality of leadership,
not only just understanding
this, but really
continually driving it.
And that developers
are customers
and should be prosperous.
I love that idea.
And then, I liked your idea that
with digital transformation,
there's often this focus
of new things and new ways,
but critically
stuffing the old ways.
Don't forget that
very important point.
Thanks very much, Paul.
KIKI MARCONDES: All right,
thank you very much.
That was really interesting.
Now we're going
to take some more
questions from the audience.
And as a reminder,
please use the link here
to ask questions or
click on the Ask Question
button on your Watch page.
All right, so we have
another question here.
So what can other
territories who
have yet to do anything
around open banking
learn from what the EU
and the UK have done?
PAUL ROHAN: I think
there are actually
quite a distinct
difference between how
the EU has approached this and
how the UK has approached it.
So the UK has embarked
on this initiative, which
was driven to create more
competition in retail banking
before PSD2 came on the horizon.
And in some ways it definitely
has an implementation body
and has more precise
guidance on how
services should be designed.
And for countries
that are thinking
about moving into a
world of open banking,
the UK provides a
fantastic template
that mobilizes your banking
community quite quickly.
And where I think the EU is
interesting and globally is
it has a huge regulatory
machine because since the 1960s,
Europe has been creating
a single market.
So there's the perception
that this is all new red tape.
No, it's just a
centralisation of red tape.
And Europe hasn't been
leader in digital.
And they're working very,
very hard to make that happen.
But I wouldn't look
at PSD2 in isolation.
So PSD2 is looking
for API connectivity
between banks and third parties.
It's setting out conduct rules.
But there's things like GDPR
or setting out expectations
around consent.
And there is European work going
on around identity, privacy.
And so I think where the rest
of the world should look to
is whether your
regulator is going
to be very precise about rules
or whether your regulator
is going to give general
guidance around principles.
What this work that's
happening in Europe identifies
is the world is going
incredibly digital.
Organizations are going to
be connected to each other.
And regulators will have
expectations of good behavior
and bad behavior.
And it's in the interests
of the leadership
and the board of directors
of an organization
to go, what are these
regulators defining
as good behavior and bad
behavior in terms of conduct
by enterprises?
And whether we have
a regulation or not,
we should take that
as our cue to protect
our brand in the long term.
When we write policy documents
about being in ecosystems,
what is our policy
around consent?
When we say to our
customers, we have partners,
what do we mean by partners?
When we say to our customers,
we're partnering with somebody,
how do we make it absolutely
plain and simple to them
that we're doing this bit,
the partner is doing that bit?
We're taking proper care that
we're choosing good partners.
But you still need to
read the instructions.
So I think for
organizations that
aren't in the
regulatory space, you
have the luxury of not having
to obsess over what are they
saying in Article
58, but go back
to the preamble of
the documentation
when they say why
they're doing it.
These are the type
of outcomes that we
want in terms of consumer
trust and consumer protection,
and that these powerful
organizations don't
abuse their position.
So when you read
why they're doing it
and the expectations they have
generally about conduct, that's
a very useful starting
point, because one
of the things that's holding up
organizations getting heavily
engaged in ecosystems
is going, we
don't have any policy documents
from risk department about how
we should conduct ourselves.
Well, copy and
paste the principles
that the regulators
are espousing,
and maybe be glad you don't
have to follow detailed rules
that regulators have written.
OLIVER OGG: Great.
KIKI MARCONDES: Great.
OK, so thanks so much
for the questions.
I hope you found this
useful and interesting.
We also would love to
hear your feedback,
so please send your
thoughts via the feedback
form that you can
see here the link.
And also stay tuned because
we have the next online meetup
coming in March 27.
So please send your
ideas so we can make
the next edition even better.
And with that, we are getting
to the end of today's session.
Thanks so much for joining us.
Have a great Christmas,
and I see you next time.